last first day when we met for dinner we
could celebrate
birthday of a close friend of the three
of you Bob Dylan Wesson Bob Dylan comes
in in terms of the counterculture why
this huge impact of this one single man
on the counterculture by a girlfriend I
mean for me it was everything a girl as
a girl I was just wanted him to be my
boyfriend you know he had like a special
magnetism and he kept evolving like
Picasso you know it was like every
record he he went into a new shift he
kept evolving we evolved with him I mean
he was like all the things we were
thinking about he he seemed to say the
way we really wanted to address it was
like it seemed like everything he did
was right where we wanted to be even you
know if there were 20 pairs of
sunglasses he picked the right ones he
had the right he had the right way of
walking but and all his idea you know he
gave us protest music he gave us you
know social awareness
he gave us you know you know sexuality
he gave us love love songs he he never
you know he just seemed everything you'd
want like if you had Arthur Rimbaud
suddenly living in your time you know it
was like that's that's what he was like
to me all the people that I loved in the
past because I lived so much in the past
finally one of these guys was living in
my time one of these guys was alive
writing poetry and and and and giving of
himself while we're alive I could
finally like a guy that wasn't dead
I think what I learned from him you know
I was pretty top 40 and listening to
rhythm blues and do up but what he
taught me was that about the sound of
his voice that he had such a strange and
bizarre voice that had expanded my idea
of what a voice could be that once I got
used to how he phrased in the tomber of
his voice and the things he was saying
and his sense of humor you know talking
World War three blues it really gave a
sense of expansion and then he kept
going you know I mean I wanted to be a
lonely folk singer in the backyard when
I got my first guitar and you know a
year later especially after the English
invasion and you know every folky was
you know this is the end of you know
music you know hope my god
you know these bands from England and I
was absolutely charmed yeah and and all
of a sudden here's a folky who was
pretty resolute who said yeah I'm gonna
plug in and all of a sudden these these
universes came together and you know
lyrically I mean he he took he made
lyrics into a whole nother animal even
beyond what the folkies were doing and
created a sound that you know I
certainly changed my life well I think
the sound is there but a good friend of
you guys and I know a bit well Harry
Smith who was important to the whole
folk movement once said that he knew
that God existed when he heard Bob Dylan
on the radio
it's a very hairy way of thinking things
but but but yes and there was a sense
that these things were opening up that
you could not hear anywhere else
and yeah I mean Dylan starts out on the
folk scene and you know there's a lot of
folk singers and it was a movement and
Joan Baez we had a beautiful voice and
Joan Baez had a lot to do with making
Bob Dylan popular and there were lots of
other folk singers around and and he was
one of them and he was a good one of
them but then he sits down and writes a
song like a hard rain's gonna fall and
that's that's of a whole different order
poetically I mean when that album came
out I remember that album coming out and
and and that song split my mind open in
a way that few other things have ever
have ever done I mean the cover of that
album was great too because he was
walking with Suze Rotolo his girlfriend
and you know that was so hip yeah I
wanted his what was so important about
about that song why why because Allen
Ginsberg also said something like it
when he hit the song I knew you know the
torch has been passed to the next
generation that's true well first of all
there's just the imagery this this you
know the imagery itself I mean just
listen to the song and you any one of
them drums ablaze and branches with that
are bleeding I mean he once said that he
was trying to write you know it was like
every line in that songs like the first
line of another song you know that that
and and and and it's all it's all pulled
together and it's and it's a song it's a
song of complete bleakness and of terror
and of Apocalypse that ends with
Redemption and ends with you know with
with with prophecy and I think that's
what Allen saw in it but I didn't I know
if I didn't I even figured out at the
time all I knew were their reasons words
that were saying things that I'd never
heard said before in a popular musical
vein and and and it was part of the
democratization I think you're talking
about opening it up I mean Dylan made
made that stuff accessible in ways that
other people couldn't
he brought poetry to the masses because
I mean for me listening to it I mean I
had read season and hell I'd read
illuminations so I could see that
was you know hard rain is going to fall
made total sense to me because it's very
remote Ian you know there's certain
lines that are almost right out of Rambo
and but he you know I was reading Rambo
and probably in South Jersey it there's
probably one copy of illuminations and I
had it you know but but then suddenly he
is writing these songs that brings this
you know because he cherished grambo as
well brings all of his knowledge of
poetry all of his ability to synthesize
all of his things that were having
politically social injustice his love of
poetry you know he was a he was our
Alchemist he put all of these things
together and created songs that even
though they were elevated were still
accessible and you know so I I think
that was you know he he gave us in one
song that particular song the state of
the world pollution you know and
injustice you know all the things that
you know crimes against children all of
these things in one song as well as
giving us poetry and you know so so
everything was like you know it was
almost subconsciously we were getting
quite an education through one song
Patti said to I mean and and Lenny he
kept moving I mean he was a year ahead
of everybody at one point and and that's
why the people were getting so upset in
part but but he kept he kept like
Picasso they're artists of different
kinds of forms and there are people of
periods who keep moving and he never
stopped
he still hasn't stopped he's still doing
it and it's why I love him so much so
that's part of it as well you know he
was see when we were having to he gave a
he taught us a great deal but then as
soon as we caught on he was somewhere
else and we were having to catch up with
that too and I was waiting for him
[Laughter]
you